olá a todos votaram é é as apresentações
já estão feitas e hoje como tema era o
world next o próximo passo e eu estava
longe de imaginar que recuperando um
pouco da minha história quanto física
quando alguém se lembrou de cobrar a
minha festa do terceiro aniversário
dentro da fábrica na altura dos meus
avós que seria com as bodas de prata
deus estavam já traçaram um cara que eu
quero é o próximo passo que é uma coisa
normal mas essas fotografias lembraram
que ele estava disponível em alguma
parte do meu futuro mas aquilo que
queria trazer e vou falar sobre justiça
como é evidente é entrar numa fila que
está baseada em portugal que é líder
mundial em nós apesar de sermos campeões
europeus de futebol de termos alguns
exemplos liderança mundial felizmente
não são assim tão pouco em termos
setoriais não há muitos que possam levar
portugal para o mundo como provavelmente
póssa a fileira da cortiça
nós vivemos e quando percebe qual é o
próximo passo da humanidade a pensando
hoje um líder o que pode comprometer a
sociedade que seja realmente diferente
quando nós vivemos com conceitos de
liberdade de trabalho e econômicos
melhoria da condição de vida de fome é
tão se tão desmobilizados então os
deputados naquilo que é o nosso
conhecimento
eu penso que o próximo grande passo e
nós pensarmos no modelo econômico possa
passar daquilo que é a economia que nós
conhecemos até hoje muito implementada
pela revolução industrial e agora também
neste mundo digital
mas que é uma economia linear onde
aproveitamos matérias primas
transformamos depois temos que depositar
em um novo modelo de economia circular a
que o que temos de pensar e pensar como
é que foi utilizar matérias como é que
vamos preencher esse vazio falta de
matéria prima como é que temos
ritualizar o setor da cortiça é alto
pódio e que representa isso muito bem
não viaja é quase um paradoxo porque na
cortiça no limite
quanto mais a explorar montado quanto
mais se tiver a nossa fila do ponto
vista no mercado ponto de vista
industrial mais apelativos será para o
protocolo está podia ter mais cortiça
mais frete e vai criar rendimento
econômico de fato todo o setor hoje
pensa nem
formas de como poderá reciclar
reutilizar redesenhar a regenerar a
tepco o montado é uma é uma uma floresta
que gera naturalmente e portanto a
notícia nesse sentido é aproveitado
desde a matéria-prima mais nobre do
hotel pó branco já energia nada é
desperdiçado e que a idéia do ponto de
vista da descarbonização da sociedade a
proteção da biodiversidade já vimos isso
hoje da conservação do sistema
hidrológico do sol uma forma realmente
única no mundo
esta é uma imagem do montado de facto há
pouco as paisagens isto é é um ser
retirada no sul de portugal pela sua vez
irá uma forma no funcional que hoje
temos no montado
conseguimos ter valores completamente
diferentes de outras áreas florestais e
mais densas mais intensas nós hoje em
portugal temos uma densidade nos nossos
contatos cerca de 80 anos por hectare
podemos facilmente chegaram estranhar
vôos fretados em prejudicar minimamente
esta paisagem sempre ficar minimamente
aquilo que o montado para oferecer tanto
no mesma área 1 730 setecentos e
quarenta mil hectares de montado
floresta do sobreiro é uma montada uma
palavra também muito portuguesa que
temos no nosso país conseguimos aumentar
significativamente a produção sem
comprometer nada dessa história que está
por trás desta floresta que tem uma
paisagem única que consegue produzir e
uma série de nós chamamos as
externalidades positivas ou banhos
públicos que servem para a sociedade que
servem para as populações locais servem
até para fixar pessoas em zonas menor
investimento que outras áreas do mundo
não conseguem ter as florestas
descobriram os montados situam sortudo
ou apenas na bacia ocidental um declínio
temos quer no sul portugal espanha e no
norte da áfrica
portugal tem um terço da área mundial de
surdos produz 50% da cortiça isso também
mostra que as nossas florestas nossos
contatos foram geridos formas diferentes
de outras regiões do mundo
além disso como já disse é uma área
brilhante ou quase inigualável do ponto
de vista da proteção da biodiversidade e
da proteção quer da parte da flora quer
da parte animal foi considerado aliás um
dos 20
copos potes mundiais biodiversidade
coloca esta região do planeta em
competição
o floresta amazônica o cos florestas do
bornéu
além disso a marca uma característica
única e por isso a palavra montado é uma
palavra portuguesa que não tem tradução
mas que explica uma floresta dos brics
combina a vida econômica o homem ea
natureza e de uma forma única e só
existem em portugal na espanha uma
palavra utilizam que reza mas não é
exatamente a mesma coisa e estamos a
falar de uma atividade agrícola o que é
uma das mais bem pagas do mundo hoje um
homem ou uma mulher que trabalham na
extração da cortiça pode ter um
rendimento de cerca de 100 euros por dia
o que de facto nos coloca em comparação
com algumas das regiões mais ricas do
mundo sublinha suplantando até lá a
algumas zonas da califórnia até o norte
europa e esparsas não é nenhum destes
países mas em portugal em zonas muitas
vezes favorecidas da floresta e os fred
tem sido quase a última oportunidade
para estas posições
esta semana quando tentava explorar esta
esta apresentação a minha tia sugeriu
que utilizasse esta esta imagem mais
jovem é o torçamos ferdinand está um
filme da disney em 1938 ea disney aqui
estava andarmos aqui uma mensagem não
imaginava mas foi recuperar podem ver o
fernando foi crescendo e ao longo da
vida foi ser ao pé de um sobreiro
esperam um vídeo da disney mas que
tratavam touro espaço no sul de espanha
e então as rolhas na parada disney que
se ão nas árvores e portanto as folhas
eram uma espécie de fruto é não é
totalmente descabido mesmo hoje com mais
de 70 anos depois
quase 30 anos depois de 80 anos depois
porque dá muita gente no mundo que acha
que as rolhas crescendo as árvores
há quem ache também aqui uma espécie de
bogotá ter crédito no terra
mas de facto nem toda a gente sabe
exatamente como é que se faça uma rolha
de cortiça e todo ferdinando foi
crescendo e foi passando e foi
escrevendo isso com isso irá mas acho
muito curioso como é que eles nem também
antecipava os sinais dos tempos várias
notícias podem ser feitas desta forma
aproveitando uma peça de cortiça natural
estamos a falar realmente o ex líbris do
as rolhas de cortiça das flores naturais
mas podem ter outros formatos
as rolhas de cortiça são um produto mais
um vant mais importante da nossa fila
irã representam 70 por cento daquilo que
são as nossas exportações e em portugal
produzem cerca de 40 milhões de euros
por dia o que dá uma liderança
claríssima da cortiça em termos mundiais
conferência de 7 em cada 10 garrafas de
vinhos engarrafados no mundo anualmente
a optarem por uma rolha de cortiça
o cça 12 mil milhões de garrafas de
televisão cortiça por aqui qualquer
coisa como 400 folhas por segundo são
abertas no mundo
agora já vai 800 e r 600
agora um pouco menos porque agora é
agora imaginem o que isto é na noite do
final do ano quando a justiça está na
casa dos milhões e milhões de pessoas
e de facto questão de liderança mundial
parte muito portugal parte portugal
porque somos claramente o líder mundial
das exportações de cortiça
estamos muito próximos de atingir os mil
milhões de euros ou dificilmente
chegaremos lá em 2007 mas em 2008
estamos convencidos que vamos atingir
esse número que é um número de alguma
maneira simbólica mas mais de quatro
dígitos mil milhões mais golos antes do
que assim número global é passarmos a
idéia também porque é um setor do
altíssimo valor acrescentado ao
contrário de outras áreas da actividade
em portugal por cada euro que é
exportado produtos em cortiça 85
cêntimos ficam em portugal tanto valor
acrescentado com as nossas exportações e
isso é muito comovente sobretudo no
contexto econômico em que vivemos em que
falávamos dos desenhos e do reino unido
erotismo 16 esta fotografia conta pra ir
pra algum sim para outros não
não tem nenhuma de um rapaz temos
teremos que considerar mas aqui também
podemos ver a forma como a notícia pode
ser aproveitado em tudo quero uma rolha
mas também para produzir uma peça de
joalharia ou uma 11 um colar que esta
festa no museu utiliza e mais atrás de
uma forma quase despercebida mas podem
ter também um papel curtis em cortiça
natural podem fazer também outras
aplicações como por exemplo isolamento
para pretos para diferentes edifícios
aqui estamos a falar num hotel e nem
o produto que é o número natural
expandido o único que toca uma rolha de
cortiça natural não leva nenhum produto
químico é 100% natural é própria
sobrinha que faz parte da cortiça carlo
mera os diferentes granos da cortiça e
facto utilizado uma forma hoje massiva
pelo mundo tem uma grande diferença é
uma grande potência da parte dos
designers decoradores preço do material
que pela sua cor
até pela sua dinâmica vai se alterando
ao longo da vida tem ganho hoje uma nova
dimensão
mas a justiça não se esgota nas rochas
da justiça hoje pode ser uma série de
aplicações quer naquela que é visível
com algumas das peças que vemos quer
naquilo que chama cortiça invisível a
cortiça combinada com outros materiais
mas que pela sua composição
pelas suas características podem
conferir aos produtos ao único e
diferenciador por exemplo motorola e
utilizar partes e qual é a razão muito
simples destas torres são colocadas no
mar do norte no norte europa onde faz
muito frio ea cortiça que faz parte das
duas partes de torres eólicas evita que
haja formação de gelo
nestas quase e permita que estas paz
trabalha mesmo em condições de
temperaturas muito baixas pois nos
transportes quando falamos de transporte
falamos de peso peso reduzir consumo ea
cortiça pode pelas suas características
quer isolamento térmico e acústico que
tu visa conferir alguns destes destes
produtos é características únicas e até
os pés chatos que utiliza cortiça no seu
na sua composição sobretudo na parte da
frente porque é o único material que
permite que os pais já deu a voltar à
atmosfera não sofra é andar nos velhos
que possam pôr em causa a sua entrada
novamente na terra aqui uma escultura do
viu seu data center da pt na confiança
também ouviu seu sacrifício e aqui o
rosto alguns trabalhadores do setor onde
claramente se pode ver que a justiça
possa ganhar outra dimensão
outra vida a justiça tem esta
característica e o amor dizia que
aconteceu e sexy
eu gosto de se ter mais do campus disse
estar na moda porque a moda pode ser
efêmera mas o facto nós dois temos uma
clara preferência dos consumidores em
todo mundo é óbvio no mundo vincou maior
convivência
além dos novos e dos dois carros que
sete em cada dez optou por uma rolha
cissa também os consumidores vindo de
uma forma geral optam pela cortiça e
dizem diferentes a cortiça está
associada a vinda de melhor qualidade
a cortiça tem a preferência clara dos
consumidores e inclusiva exercendo
estudos que temos desenvolvido
os consumidores estão disponíveis para
pagar mais por uma garrafa de vinho como
uma rolha de cortiça nos estados unidos
num trabalho que já fazemos há sete anos
em média uma garrafa de vinho com uma
rolha de cortiça vol 4 dólares mais do
que uma garrafa de vinho com um jantar
oficial está manhã valor por nosso setor
mas o valor também para os nossos
clientes
esta é uma fotografia que combina um
sobreiro com o pavilhão de portugal em
chegar e estes jovens
este jovem asiático promete chineses
quando foi o ouvido em que estava o
programa portugal e voltou até marvel
provavelmente estamos aqui a dar uma
imagem de como é que um produto
português vários nacional mas com uma
visão global do mundo pode alcançar
todas as geografias todas as gerações e
este jovem possivelmente não deve na
viagem à china o consumo de vinho per
capita são 0.6 livros ano por pessoa
comparados com 52 litros por pessoa é em
portugal há um longo caminho para
concorrer aos prêmios os chineses não
desmatem todos a viver vi rapidamente
não tínhamos também um problema mas
dizer vos que temos em portugal é que
este é um exemplo único também como é
que podemos levar a marca de portugal
para o mundo como é que podemos
alavancar também no nosso país mostrar
que somos capazes de fazer parte deste
mundo novo
o mundo da economia circular um mundo
onde claramente temos que olhar o
planeta com outra atenção porque o
planeta solar vou falar também com todos
nós e as gerações que vêm a seguir
possam ter uma vida saudável e o próximo
passo para isso e não querendo entrar em
discussões políticas florestais ele acha
que é interdito nos modelos da terex
dizer vos que este pode ser o próximo
passo
plantaram sobre pode querer dizer que
foi mais riqueza para portugal num
futuro não muito longínquo e pode trazer
melhor modo de vida quer para as
populações locais quer para o país em
geral e por isso vai economizar e
portugal para o mundo porque os
portugueses são diferentes porque sabem
fazer bem e todos
fazer certamente muito melhor e como as
imagens valem mais do que mil palavras
vou terminar com um tiro
[Música]
corte israelense nesta peça foi preserve
online não de santos íris valas onde
temos diversos ramos de 11 mil por alto
o estado se esta não era fazendo
shoppings
[Música]
e sabe sim a essa distância do ilsi esta
grande fluxo forte em caxito o sporting
de gijón
[Música]
sou ine e do newell's pagas fez quatro
isso isso
santos pires de camargo não fora prefere
pacote hipótese para evitar o terceiro
do ranking são doce ao coco fosse willey
do óleo site ou se prefere 30 fiquei
imóvel de cinco raças haiti
a última turnê de estado e sim de vinhos
em cork expuser alguém da fitch é melhor
fecho corte mote morda me disse ai
direito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]